one of my favs Gillian Jacob hi Gillian
how are you you got our mic on there you
go you are welcome long time first time
that's right
well never done before yeah yeah it was
a joke guys sorry we don't get jokes
here we don't this isn't a humorous show
okay we're to tackle the issue oh I
remember
right right right you look very colorful
thank you so much pink jacket and the
bright green shirt it's very nice thank
you are you live streaming this um no we
just we're the camera's not
live-streaming
hello cameras that's right we just keep
everything for our records discuss how
we were yeah yeah yes yes just meetings
how can we improve like how does our
body language change how can we make it
worse welcome thank you
um so does it excite you you're you're
here - because you're in Ibiza correct
which is coming out on Netflix
yes May 25th same time yesterday netflix
announces the Obamas are you going to
start producing this right all right
yeah are you sitting there being like
why couldn't the Obamas have produced
Ibiza that would be amazing remarkable
right I know I know
well maybe they can produce the sequel
but that's right because you got Ibiza
right yes you got love all multiples
with three seasons of love right yes
right so obviously you're a Netflix
darling just absolute darling
right so you get a sash multiple
projects with Netflix they give you a
sash Netflix darling right so now that
your Netflix darling do you think to
yourself I got to figure out how to get
in with these Obamas I think anyone
who's ever been on Netflix yesterday
just just people who had had random
movies picked up like wow I had a thing
that was on Netflix for a period of time
no I heard that as a hammer I was
do you I thought of that sure yesterday
for some reason it was a good show I
should go back and watch demons end yeah
yeah like a bob guy in hiding what we're
supposed to be sweet you're betraying my
ignorance I'm not great at geography I
don't know either but I just remember it
was sure the listeners will tell us they
well it didn't grab they'll be kind it
did not grab me I didn't hate it but I
remember I just didn't what's your
favorite show right now
what has grabbed you I like y'all chapo
I'm not really watching I think narcos
okay I'm not really watching anything at
all
no it's nothing no I I have to tell you
always watching Ibiza and I don't know
it made me think about myself okay
because literally the entire movie I was
waiting for you guys to get taken we
have a nod to that from start to finish
calm adventure friendship movie but
you're just still waiting for that to
happen and I was like maybe maybe I've
become I don't know if it's what what
cultures done to me what film has done
to me but yeah it's three girls hmm and
they're in a foreign country it's Spain
but they're in a foreign country in the
whole time and they're like just trying
to find their way around and they meet
wacky characters and stuff like that and
I'm like okay well they didn't get taken
that time that's the one who's gonna
take them did i watch all the way
through waiting for disaster destroyed
goodness it doesn't strike there's a
disaster movie it's not yes it's a
rom-com as advertised
we're not misleading you ignore that it
was like an action thriller and then it
just turned out to be a rom-com so no
there was something in me that said this
rom-com well maybe you should write that
version of the film it we can do it I
will and I lie but I won't advertise it
as I do you don't I saw the trailer too
yesterday totally it was that was that a
quiet place uh-huh yeah that I want to
see there should be really really good
yeah I haven't seen it we can all go the
three of us after you do your hours long
recap of the show today we can all go to
the movies yeah it's a private recap
yeah I just do
I'll wait in the greenroom good are you
still having to wake up at like really
strange hours and has your life yours
improved it's a little bit better now I
get up at 5:25 every morning okay that's
not not bad that bad
it's do pared to what you were doing
before no yeah I've had periods in my
life where it was like 3:30 yeah which
is insane
no how long can you sustain that I don't
know I don't I mean I don't know yeah I
yeah I don't I don't think you're
supposed to sustain it for any real
manageable period of time they say the
health effects you get from not sleeping
you can never make that up great that's
it really encouraging right I feel
wonderful
that's all these years of television
right no it's bad but can't you make up
like like it does bad damage you yet to
your body in your brain oh and that's
not healable they say so I don't believe
that you don't know he'll never get up
let's [ __ ] a lot of people have lack of
sleep for a while I'm saying this
because I'm 49 I don't sleep at all so
is that a recent thing or is I didn't
always think since I was seven really
seven years like baby because you were
me yeah I don't know what it is it
stinks I'm sorry it's okay
what do you do to lay there really wish
I had a better actor for you I literally
just lay there contemplate yeah did life
decisions and things like that it's
horrifying can you believe that Donald
Glover has become the biggest star in
like the world yes you can absolutely do
you think that this was like why did it
take so long exactly as I kind of can't
believe because with everything that
he's he's been doing all of this this
whole entire time there's nothing
surprising about this to me you saw this
coming when as soon as I met him really
yeah so you're doing community mm-hmm
and you're like this guy has all these
talents yes he's gonna start using all
these they're even more talents he's an
amazing artist as well there's will
artists so like a painter like drawings
yeah there's nothing he can't do how did
you find out he was leaving he told us
yeah I think you know obviously now
seeing Atlanta and everything he's doing
he had other things in his brain
I respect that what is it like being
around a person who works on that level
you should know but like you start to
we're incredibly hard-working you know
it would be like in between takes on
community and he'd be in the corner like
writing music or writing a script or
working on a stand-up or you know so I
really saw the dedication that it took
but does it make you be like I got to
pick up the clarinet or something I got
to do something more no because it all
comes so naturally and effortlessly to
him right and he was yeah he's such a
hard worker like he would do this show
at UCB Sunday nights at like midnight
and then we'd have to be at work you
know 6 a.m. on Monday and I'm how do you
do that he's like what just that's the
show I do it every Sunday night I could
not I couldn't do it do you do a walk of
a project like that that was going well
that you didn't need to walk off of like
I'm surprised that he left what it was
still going well no I don't I tend to
stay till the end
yeah drugs and sex on Yahoo so yeah I
stayed no I've never left anything um
but I understand it more you know I I
understand watching everything that he's
done you know he's he's so talented like
I but I'm like very I'm much more like
the contract says six years so I'll do
six years like I you know I wish I had a
little bit more of his well everything
do it there's balls 2 or 2 to walk out
and go yeah I'm gonna get something else
or I'm gonna do something else I'm so
paranoid that anything I'm doing is the
final thing I'm doing absolutely this is
my last job
yeah there's also something about like
when somebody offers you a job and
you're like oh my god they're offering
me a job yes I'll do it I yes I'll do it
I know I'm trying to get a little bit
better about not just like saying yes to
things just so I can say I have a job
because you just go from thing to thing
to thing to thing and sometimes you wind
up there and you're like why so tired so
I'm trying to I'm trying to slow down a
bit more well you're at a place now
where you've got a lot under your belt
that's true you know I feel like you've
been you've been creeping up on
everybody
seemed like every six months that's
description of my career I've ever heard
lava like every six months there's
another pretty big deal thing
all right cool like I feel like we were
just talking about love season three
yeah and then this now this movie that
you're in like every scene for and then
the movie with Melissa McCarthy yeah so
your cut your ear you're everywhere good
that was the intention from the goal
that's what I said to my agents I want
to be everywhere everywhere ears pierced
like weird question but yes well for the
listeners I got my ears pierced on Jimmy
Kimmel on Friday um I had never had my
ears pierced before I'd been thinking
about it for like the last I'd say like
year I actually offered on love I told
Paul rust that I would do it on camera
the first scene on love if they wanted
to because I like have these ideas but
I'm just so sedentary that unless I'm
forced to do it like telling a talk show
I'm gonna do it I'll just sit in my
living room right so I figured I want to
pierce my ears why not do it at this
point and so I thought if I have to do
it on camera then it will actually
happen and they'll like find the person
into everything and I just have to show
up right course you're accountable for
it now yeah like it has so now I have my
ears pierced did it hurt yeah it did not
like the worst pain I've ever been in it
seemed like it didn't hurt that much you
were like oh that wasn't that bad
yeah I mean it hurt like a tiny little
needle going through your ear yes right
i mean i i'd like i said on the show i
saw Kyle Richards small child get her
ears pierced on the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills and she seemed in agony so
I was too afraid it wasn't as bad as I
thought it would be you're an adult
am i just to annoy everybody in this
studio yeah you don't know that the look
I'm I want to go for one day to really
but I want to bleach my hair okay and
wear a red suit again my ears pierced do
you have a style inspiration for this no
just I I just that would just be me
like a bright fire engine red chilly
that's what's in me are you gonna grow
your hair out so there's more to bleed a
little bit yeah
very long I'm a man or maroon the
gentleman a gentleman's burger right of
course yes of course yes of course
because you want to be treated with
respect you're not a joke younger get a
register no what better way than a
gentleman's burgundy shaves the ears off
yes
now what kind of what kind of earrings
are you thinking pie studs I don't know
oh you could have a chandelier earring
there's so many options notice I did
think of a couple of Hoops sure that's
pretty cool
all right one in each year Marv you
gonna do clip-ons are you gonna actually
pierce you know I have to pierce would
be cool right just to be cool clip-on
earrings aren't cool piercing your ears
is really cool yeah I'm cool now finally
I was just thinking that would that be
annoying if I walked up my ears pierced
maybe dude I'd be furious well why would
that make you furious because it's like
what are you doing why he's living his
life he isn't though this isn't him this
wouldn't he he'd be searching for
something he's right it just wasn't
there it would be Jim dealing with more
demons inappropriately like this is not
we have not even sort of tackle the
outside in right instead of inside out
okay yeah the creep puts on another
costume right exactly we're just lying
about ourselves again and it what if
you're like in intensive therapy and you
start working I did just start therapy
but I'm not intensive with it be a
prophet I think you'd be yeah we could
up the number of times a week you're
going have you start going three or four
times a week I'd be okay with a maroon
suit I want it I do want to bleach the
hair and wear the earrings more than the
suit okay thinking about for a while I
would the late nineties because last
night I just think of how annoyed
everybody would be gosh that's your life
just trying to enjoy those around you
that's why Jim can't sleep is just
envisioning what future Jim well what
was your style icon when you're in high
school or but Dwyer you know I don't
really have one you can tell me I dress
the same way on some pants and waffle
sneakers in the Sabbath show I don't
I'm terrible who was your style icon I
asked a question that I don't have an
answer for um who was my mind would be
something like Katharine Hepburn
right yeah right I was into Katharine
Hepburn so were you really yes why um I
think my mom thought she would be a good
role model for me as an actress and I
liked her movies and I read a lot of
biographies about her when I was a kid
so I don't know I lost I watched a lot
of Katharine Hepburn movies my friend
Ken Ober did some weird thing he told me
about many years ago with Hepburn where
he did some he helped her for the day
really he had to spend the day with her
yeah and she was really sweet and she
really liked him so I think she wanted
to write him a check Leah thank you yeah
and he said no and I don't want but he
said he wishes he would have gotten it
now just have a chat with Katharine
Hepburn Arden you never met her no no
that's unfortunate cause she married you
well she Bogart's wife and no she was in
a long relationship with Spencer Tracy
but they were never married but she had
a couple she had at least one marriage
before that hmm fun facts the listeners
are riveted you really do know Katherine
her I do I do
Katharine who is the daughter and guess
who's coming to dinner I just like
throwing out a question okay nobody will
care about I think that was her real
life nice all was it a Tharin Houghton I
want to say but don't I I think you're
right what someone could look it up I
just didn't what to say when you said
Spencer Tracy and Katherine Hepburn I
like that movie but it doesn't
necessarily hold up I've never seen that
one I liked no I liked her like Cary
Grant comedies a lot like bringing up
baby the Philadelphia Story enjoyed them
as a child on Golden Pond I never
watched that one and later ones I'm so
sorry kind of Katharine Hepburn fan
doesn't like a golden I like have you
ever seen holiday no I have I've seen it
seen you haven't done gold upon I was 13
1981 and I want Fonda Jane Fonda Dabney
Coleman was in that Henry Fonda and I
went with a buddy of mine and I wanted
to see there was a 3d horror movie out
at that time but I don't remember what
it was but I allowed him my Haley who is
more cultured Robert Levinson was mama
they wouldn't they were nice people and
they got me to go some higher and I'm
like this looks like [ __ ] I don't want
to see two old people on a stupid lake
right and it was great made me cry it
was like a grave it is a thirteen year
old it was amazing you developed empathy
in that moment I did yeah but I wanted
to see the horror movie I never saw the
horror movie but it won Best Actor Best
Actress surprisingly destroyed on Golden
Pond nothing
sharknado you know swept the off
incredible pain you never have seen that
or guess what's coming I'm stunned that
you're a Katharine Hepburn
I like the early ones yeah I can see the
shape of your face in your hair it's
definitely definitely something there
did you shape your face after definitely
is Katharine Hepburn oh thank you could
you succeeding we really do sell like
old hens yeah I think I've seen Billy
Madison happy gilmore that's good too
sure yeah all kinds of good movie what
else is going on there's a man who is
peeing in flight that's how you know
that's how you know an interview is
going off into a weird place when the
guest picks up a paper goes so what else
is going on I see the stream of urine I
was on a flight oh that guy you can make
it to the bathroom no that was an angry
Frontier Airlines yeah I think he was
drunk and parent I know he was doing I
he was he just got done filming Breaking
Bad and he was being uh we were
analyzing this photo it's a guy right
and he's sitting in his airline seat and
he's pissing on the seat that's in front
of him and they blur out you know the
private area but you could still clearly
see the piss stream yeah I can and he's
not even blurred out there his dick is
just small oh here's a here's what we
saw in the analysis okay the stream it
appears that he's aiming it directly in
the cupholder section well that's kind
of the pouch okay so we think that he's
specifically trying to fill up that back
small pouch with his urine um I guess
better than trying to pee in between the
seats onto the people sitting in front
of him well yeah he was they said he'd
like touched her groped women or was
making shitty comments as being an
[ __ ] no I know I was as shocked as
you are when I heard it but
oh this is horrible this you have it's
the greatest photo I've ever seen that
should that's literally that reminds me
of the the girl running in Vietnam
excellent the window that's the level of
that phone over that's the level of
capturing a moment in the world was like
this is like something Annie Leibowitz
should have caught it's one of those
things that you just will never be able
to replicate that man he's desperately
trying not to piss on himself and he's
cool but he's clearly aiming it into the
pouch but he's not even stretching the
pouch open but dude he's got this nice
knot yeah that hook it's it's amazing
you know look at that look at that nice
that nice arc and the curve with this -
he's an older guy incredible size at all
but at 45 it's not to be taken for
granted that he could have a stream that
powerful and I like Troy am i right he's
right it's really what happens to men's
urine
it's the prostate issues what I'm
standing I still can't hit my balls to
me okay tell me what happens the fact
you just you lose your ability cuz I
guess your body changes you lose your
ability to fire it out really so what's
happening then it's just like a trickle
that's really yeah if anything's coming
out of there it's dribbling I have to go
as bad as you thought you did because
your body's telling you got to go and
you don't got that all the time I have a
tiny bladder I think I went to fun facts
we were doing shows in Los Angeles last
week Jim literally was peeing every 45
minutes are you drinking a lot of water
no coffee
oh you need to alternate water and
coffee yeah I try to but yeah I pee a
lot okay well we sure like flushing out
your system but not on the airplane in
the bathroom on the airplane but not on
the seat [ __ ] like what do you think
there's another thing on an airline
yesterday where two deaf people I guess
some guy on the flight they said punched
her a punch their service dog what and
these did read that oh my god what a
[ __ ] and the guy was angry PETA people
think with the guys he punched a
pregnant woman and a dog yeah that's
what it was no the guy is the guy the
guys they can't speak I love he's mute
but he can't leave he's hard to make
noise but he's [ __ ]
furious and his wife is signing at him
like let's get the [ __ ] off the plane oh
no this is horrible
right you can't see the guy who he's
going he's gone this is not good pushed
a guy this is not good I think he threw
a stanchion at Tom maybe the guy he said
the guy hit his dog or something I don't
like this okay enough of this let's talk
about something else this is why we
should be flying private oh my goodness
yeah this is why I started are you on do
they put you on this serious yes they do
yes they do
did they fly you out to LA yeah they did
that guy's sat behind us they were good
did you do them at a theater like what
why'd you have to go to LA we like to be
out there no this was oh no you can't
say that on air you had to go to LA
because it's a whole different Barbie we
love guests right love with Bobby Lee
and he lives in Los Angeles California
which is why if we want Bobby Lee on the
show you got to go to Bobby Lee exactly
we should go without working right now
is the longest I think I've gone since
community started I finished a play
April first
so okay so where's like like a month
yeah something a hand
yeah I know you're starting to get the
itch like you're like I got to do
something are you enjoying well I've
been very lucky that I had two movies
come out in May so I've been busy
promoting both of those and then once
the movie comes out on Friday then I'll
be able to take a break and we'll see
how long I can go taking a break are you
married no would you getting another
idea what do you guys do when you're off
we're never off he is equally busy as me
so that's a problem so you can't just go
away for a couple weeks we've never gone
on a vacation how long have you been
together seven years okay well if you
never got on a vacation ever huh what's
the most number of days you spent
together one after the other a lot you
just never go on vacation I see I see I
thought it's one of those things where
like you see each other like one day at
a time and then you go away no no it's
not like that that's not really that
doesn't count of seven years no no we
just don't go on vacation I see that's
good if everybody's working all the time
because you know you don't hate each
other cuz you're never around each other
sure
also a lot of people try to get into
relationships with people they don't
hate
sometimes it takes you a while to figure
out that you hate the person that's true
I've always built it up and I found that
every woman I've ever dated has come to
the same conclusion ship a couple of
years yeah
I'm really bad are you you're married
I'm married you're wrong I've been
married for five I think it's almost six
years
gratulations yeah yeah well I've been
with her for like 13 years yeah we've
been together forever so that's great
yes it's but we don't hate each other
yeah we see each other every day ya know
hey but you were on some weird hours for
a while that's true we do yeah I know
yeah you're working nights and she's
getting up in the morning in your home
and it's late you can't do it it's just
yeah how do you have a sexy butt like
that you can't there's weekend's okay
yes there's weekends for things like
that as your as your boyfriend an actor
No
so you can absolutely not did you want
to avoid that I just never really been
into actors yeah why what kind of a job
is it masculine like a sea fire for me
not in a very macho profession but he's
just he's not an actor he's not a
traveling fireman you're traveling a
fireman tries a consulting fireman no he
travels some I probably travel more than
he does right right now yes question I
have for you have to wrap up to traverse
it
Ibiza is on Netflix this Friday this
Friday May 25th it's a big party movie
it is you're not like a big party person
and you know what's about me I know so
you know this to be true right so how do
you how do you figure out how to act
like you're on ecstasy and and alcohol
and all kinds of things like that
without being like when we there's a
scene in the film in which we take
ecstasy and someone on set had to come
up to the all three actresses because
we're not really party people and be
like they don't taste great so you
should make a face like it doesn't taste
good we're like oh okay none of us had
ever done ecstasy so basically you just
have to have the humility to say I don't
know what I'm doing and be very open to
like
students and notes right from those
around you who have more experience how
they act on ecstasy they didn't tell us
how to act on ecstasy but I just think
they were like this doesn't look right
that you guys have the pill in your
mouth and you're not making any sort of
faces though there's no taste to this
and I was like oh I don't know
I didn't know there was a taste to it I
have no idea yeah like is there a drug
expert on the set just like everybody
yes we're all thankfully I've been
around people who have more know-how
than me who've led me through all the
things I've had to pretend to be on on
screen that's the one thing about acting
that's great is if you if you need
somebody who's on drugs just you always
can find somebody I've found a lot of
help